Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在我们深入今天的节目之前，我想快速通知大家一件目前正在发生的美妙事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是不断地用时间换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“向持续收入冲刺挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有志成为心理学家、心理健康从业者，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode of Marianne's Summer Soundbites, we are looking at two more brilliant strategies to help you to nourish yourself, to nurture yourself, to look after
这些原则对你同样适用。此外，还有由丽莎亲自送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一的一小时辅导。想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体渠道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。在今天的玛丽安夏季金句（Marianne's Summer Soundbites）节目中，我们将探讨另外两个绝佳的策略，帮助你滋养自己、照顾自己、关爱自己，
yourself, treat yourself as number one so you can reduce the chance of burnout and be there for your clients, your families, for everybody else too. Hope you find it so useful. The only way to be qualified is the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. Hi, welcome along to another episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. This is another of our super useful, super punchy, shorter than usual summer soundbite episodes so that you can keep psychology in your day-to-day life when you might be a little bit busier. So another series which has been really popular in the past is the free Compassionate Q&A series. And they're hosted all by me. And they're all, as I said, absolutely for free across my socials. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. But a great place to
把你自己放在首位，这样你就能减少职业倦怠的几率，并更好地为你的客户、你的家人以及身边的每个人服务。希望你觉得这非常有用。通往合格心理学家的唯一途径，就是收听由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的《有志心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。嗨，欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》的又一期节目。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。这是我们又一期超级有用、超级干货、比平时更短的夏季金句节目，以便你在日程可能有些忙碌的时候，也能将心理学融入日常生活。过去非常受欢迎的另一个系列是免费的同理心问答系列（Compassionate Q&A series）。这些全部由我主持。正如我所说，它们在我的所有社交平台上完全免费。我在所有地方都是 Dr. Marianne Trent。不过一个很好的
catch up with it is either via YouTube, which is Dr. Marianne Trent, or via my free Facebook group, which is the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. Right, let me tell you and talk you through the dates where you can grab these really useful sessions if you are applying for psychology doctorate programs in the autumn. So I know that is the case for declensi and that is the case for educational psychology too. So the first of those sessions is running on Monday the 4th of September 2023 at 6pm. The second is Tuesday the 3rd of October 2023 at 6pm. And the last but certainly not the least is Tuesday the 7th of November 2023 at 6pm. And like I said, runs across all of my social platforms. So put a note in your diary and join me then. But if you're not free that day, you can catch any replays on Dr. Marianne Trent on YouTube. And whilst you're
回看途径是通过 YouTube（搜索 Dr. Marianne Trent），或者通过我的免费 Facebook 群组——“有志心理学家社区与玛丽安·特伦特博士”（Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent）。好啦，如果你正打算在秋季申请心理学博士课程，让我来向你介绍和讲解一下你可以收看这些极具实用性直播的日期。我知道德伦西（declensi）是这样，教育心理学也是如此。这些直播的第一场将于2023年9月4日星期一晚上6点举行；第二场于2023年10月3日星期二晚上6点举行；最后一场但同样重要的是2023年11月7日星期二晚上6点。就像我说的，这些直播会在我所有的社交平台上播出。所以请在日程表上记下时间，到时加入我们。如果你那天没有空，你可以在 YouTube 上的 Dr. Marianne Trent 观看任何回放。当你在
there, why not like and subscribe, share a bit of useful content and drop me some comments. So let's plow on with the first of my strategies today for how to keep you tip top and therefore to help your clients really benefit and those around you too. So the first is for me, it's setting boundaries and knowing that that's okay to do. And it's really important that you do. Setting boundaries might look different for different people. But certainly when I was an aspiring psychologist psychologist it meant sometimes that I was having to work a little bit later in order to get reports ready for the next day's ward round or the next day's care planning meetings but I was on a system where flexi time was possible as well so
那里时，为什么不点赞、订阅、分享一些有用的内容并给我留一些评论呢？让我们继续今天的第一项策略，探讨如何保持最佳状态，从而真正造福你的客户以及你身边的人。所以第一点，对我而言，就是设定界限，并认识到这样做是没有问题的。而且你必须这样做，这一点非常重要。设定界限对不同的人来说可能表现不同。但当然，当我还是一个有志心理学家时，这意味着有时我不得不工作稍晚一点，以便为第二天的病房查房或第二天的护理计划会议准备好报告。不过当时我所在的体制也支持弹性工作制，所以
I could still choose to come in at the same time the next day, but I could then log any extra time spent 15 minutes and over doing additional duties. I could then take that back either just straight away the next day, or I could save it up and take it as a bit of a longer chunk to have a bit of a morning off or to finish early one afternoon too. Clearly, you're going to need to discuss that with your line manager and with your supervisor and if that's not the policy in your department then you might just need to be really bounded about your time, about your start and your finish times and make sure that you're not adding too much to your plate to do in any particular day. And sometimes that can feel really tricky when you want to look keen, you want to look enthusiastic, you want to be helpful.
我仍然可以选择第二天在同一时间上班，然后我可以记录任何超过15分钟的额外加班时间来执行额外职责。我既可以选择在第二天马上把时间补回来，也可以把时间攒起来，作为一个稍长一点的假期，比如休息一个上午，或者某天下午早点下班。显然，你需要与你的直线经理和主管讨论这一点，如果这不是你们部门的政策，那么你可能需要对你的时间设定明确的界限，严格规定你的上班和下班时间，并确保在任何特定的一天里，你没有给自己揽下太多的工作。有时，当你想要表现得积极、热情、乐于助人时，这可能会让人觉得非常棘手。
But sometimes you might need to just remind people of what you've already got on. So you might need to check the priority of what's being asked for you. So when someone gives you a piece of work, you say, can I ask, you know, what, when you might need that back by what, what your, what your deadline is for that. And if they say, oh, today, as soon as possible, then you might say, okay, I've already got this, that we've agreed needs to be done by today. And I'm working on that currently. So could you let me know which has the highest priority, because I need to finish at five today. And then you know, you're leveling with them, that there's only one of you. And that is honestly, okay to do. It might take a little bit of a practice. It might take talking this through in the mirror but that's okay you aren't anybody's slave you
但有时你可能只需要提醒大家你手头已经有了什么工作。所以你可能需要核对别人要求你做的事情的优先级。因此，当有人交给你一份工作时，你可以问：“请问，你需要什么时候拿回这东西？你的截止日期是什么时候？”如果他们说：“哦，今天，越快越好。”那么你可能会说：“好的，我手头已经有了这件我们一致同意必须在今天完成的工作，我目前正在处理这个。所以你能告诉我哪个优先级最高吗？因为我今天必须在5点钟下班。”然后你知道，你在向他们坦诚，你只有一个人。而且老实说，这样做是完全可以的。这可能需要一点练习，可能需要在镜子里进行彩排，但没关系，你不是任何人的奴隶，你
certainly I certainly we certainly don't get paid well enough to work 24 7 around the clock and actually when we try to do that we recognize that we start to feel pretty jaded we start to feel pretty tired and we're no use to ourselves and we're certainly no use to the service. And before you know it, you're looking for new jobs because you're working too hard and it's not working for you and it's likely not working for them. You might find that you're dropping all sorts of balls all over the place. And I know in May last year, when we spoke to Rose Dunstan for the podcast, which was way back in episode 25, she introduced us to the idea of glass and rubber balls with the idea that we
当然，我们当然，我们绝对没有拿到足够高的薪水去全天候24小时连轴转。事实上，当我们试图这样做时，我们会发现自己开始感到相当厌倦，开始感到相当疲惫，我们对自已毫无用处，对服务对象也绝对没有任何用处。不知不觉中，你就会开始寻找新工作，因为你工作太努力了，这对你没有用，对他们来说可能也没用。你可能会发现自己手忙脚乱，到处都在掉链子。我知道在去年5月，我们在播客中采访罗斯·邓斯坦（Rose Dunstan）时——那是在第25期节目中——她向我们介绍了玻璃球和橡胶球的概念，核心思想是
could afford to drop some rubber balls, but we probably couldn't and shouldn't be planning on dropping the glass ones because they're too important. And that's been a really helpful idea to myself, but also to a number of clients I've worked with as well. So if you're listening to this, thank you so much, Rose, and hope that it's all going well with you. So yeah, it might be helpful for you in your work capacity or in your study capacity for that matter. And maybe even in your personal capacity to think about which of your priorities and which of the concerns in your life are rubber balls, those you can afford to place down or to leave unattended or to just, you know, let drop,
我们可以承受掉落一些橡胶球，但我们可能不能、也不应该计划掉落玻璃球，因为它们太重要了。这个想法对我自己以及我合作过的许多客户都非常有帮助。所以如果你正在听这段节目，非常感谢你，罗斯，希望你一切都好。所以，是的，无论是在你的工作能力、学习能力方面，可能甚至在你的个人生活能力方面，思考一下你生活中的哪些优先级和哪些担忧是橡胶球——那些你可以承担放下、置之不理或者仅仅是让它们掉落的球，
and which are glass balls, those which you can't. So yeah, let me know what you think. Do come along to the Aspiring Psychologist community or any of my social media posts and discuss this with me. What are your glass balls? What are your rubber balls, so to speak? Right, let's pause here for a quick break and I'll be back along to talk through our next of our top tips for reducing burnout and keeping you vibrant. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh this and everything in your life ticking along nicely. Now we're going to look at the second of our Marianne's Summer Sandbike topics for the day. Next we are looking at the importance of seeking support and supervision. Please at this point don't let your eyes glaze over because it really is important. You know the quality of the relationship between you and your supervisor you and those in your team
而哪些是玻璃球——那些你不能掉落的球，这个想法对你可能会有所帮助。所以，是的，请让我知道你们的想法。欢迎来到“有志心理学家社区”或我的任何社交媒体帖子下与我讨论这个问题。什么是你的玻璃球？什么是你的橡胶球？好了，让我们在这里暂停一下，稍作休息，我很快就会回来，继续探讨我们的下一个顶级技巧，教你如何减少职业倦怠并保持活力。它就在这本书里——《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。这就是《临床心理学家合集》。哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，这一切以及你生活中的一切都井井有条。现在我们将探讨今天玛丽安夏季金句主题的第二个。接下来我们将探讨寻求支持和督导的重要性。请在这个时候不要让你的眼神放空，因为这真的很重要。你知道你与主管之间的关系质量，你与团队中其他人的关系，
maybe even those you're sharing an office with if that's something that you have I know when I was when I was an aspiring psychologist sometimes I didn't even have my own chair heck when I was qualified sometimes I didn't even have my own chair but you know where you are where you're spending your time day to day can be so important in the way that you're able to bring yourself to work the way you're able to bring yourself to your client work and how much good stuff is left over at the end of the day so it can be useful looking at when in the week you're having supervision because course, if you know that you're having it, I don't know, first thing on a Monday morning or first thing on a Tuesday morning, but then you're
甚至可能包括与你共用一个办公室的人（如果你有幸拥有这样的办公室的话）。我知道当我还是一个有志心理学家时，有时我甚至没有自己的椅子；见鬼，当我获得资格后，有时我甚至连自己的椅子都没有。但你知道，你所处的地方、你日复一日度过时间的地方，对于你能够以怎样的状态投入工作、以怎样的状态投入客户工作、以及一天结束时还剩下多少精力，可能会产生如此重要的影响。所以，审视你在每周的什么时候进行督导会很有用。因为当然，如果你知道你的督导安排在，我不知道，周一上班第一件事，或者周二上班第一件事，但是随后你
going right through the week and you've got lots of tricky things stacking up, then it might not be super useful for you going home on a Friday, all full up to the brim. You know, it might be better if you're able to sit and have that chat with your supervisor about what you're experiencing when you clock off for the week and how much of that you might be taking home. Because, you know, we, I speak collectively as supervisors, past and present, don't want you being so full up that you can't engage with your day to day life. You know, I really would like for you to be able to do your job, do your job well whilst you're there. But then leave it there, you know, leave it in the phone, leave it in the spreadsheet, leave it in your laptop.
要经历一整周的工作，并且堆积了许多棘手的事情，那么当你周五满载而归、精疲力竭地回家时，这可能并不是超级有用。你知道，如果你能坐下来，与你的督导畅谈你在结束一周工作打卡时所经历的感受，以及其中有多少情绪你可能会带回了家，这可能会更好。因为，你知道，我们——我作为过去和现在的督导代表大家发言——并不希望你满载负荷，以至于无法参与到日常生活中。你知道，我真的很希望你能做好你的工作，在工作时把工作做好。但随后就把工作留在那里，你知道的，把它留在电话里，留在电子表格里，留在你的笔记本电脑里。
Don't bring that home with you because it's going to really affect your window of tolerance. It's going to make it terribly thin, terribly little, not much jam in the sandwich. And yeah, before you know it, you're going to be struggling with lots and lots of things. So making sure that you're contained, and that is something that I got much better at doing as I got, as my career advanced, I found myself being able to kind of think about clients as and when I wanted to, either in a mindful way or because something I was doing or listening to or thinking of reminded me of them, but it felt pleasant to have them there. It wasn't like it was pressing down on me and feeling really heavy or that they were unwelcome in some way. So yeah, it can be really
不要把它带回家，因为这真的会影响你的容忍窗口（window of tolerance）。它会变得极其狭窄，极其微小，三明治里几乎抹不上什么果酱。是的，不知不觉中，你就会开始与许许多多事情苦苦挣扎。因此，确保你得到心理容器（contained）的支持——随着我职业生涯的发展，我在这一点上变得越来越擅长。我发现自己能够在我想的时候去思考客户，无论是通过正念的方式，还是因为我正在做的事情、听到的事情或想到的事情让我想起了他们，但把他们放在那里感觉很愉快。这并不像有什么东西在压迫着我、让我觉得非常沉重，或者觉得他们的出现某种程度上是不受欢迎的。所以，是的，思考
useful to think about the timing of your supervision. But also something I've really benefited from is the wisdom and the knowledge and the expertise of others in the team who might not even be psychologists. Not to make it sound like psychologists are the be-all and end-all, but of course this is an aspiring psychologist podcast so you've got to give me a little bit of leeway there if you have time in your diary especially at the beginning of a job it can be wonderfully enriching and rewarding to shadow other members of the team or even to ask if you could after you've shadowed a few you know run a session together run an assessment together,
督导的时机真的非常有用。此外，让我真正受益匪浅的还有团队中其他人的智慧、知识和专业技能，他们甚至可能都不是心理学家。这并不是说心理学家就是一切、是终极目标，但当然这是一个有志心理学家播客，如果你在日程表上有时间，特别是在刚开始一份工作的时候，去旁听团队其他成员的工作，甚至在旁听了几次之后，请求是否可以一起开展一次咨询、一起做一个评估，
or go and help out at a therapy group. And because you'll learn so much, but also you'll be able to bring and offer your unique skills and talents. And do bear in mind the supervision shaping tool, which is available from my website. And people have said they've been finding really useful. You can download that for yourself by going to the link in the show notes or the post description. But in case you're listening, you don't have a pen. It's www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash supervision. thank you so much for being part of my world please do subscribe like share comment tell your friends about us share us on your socials thank you so much for being part of my world and i'll be back along with the next episode of the aspiring psychologist podcast from monday at 6 a.m take care Thank you. to be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book.
或者去治疗小组帮忙，这会带来无比丰富和有益的体验。因为你不仅能学到很多东西，而且你还能够带入并发挥你独特的技能和才华。请记住可以从我的网站上获取的“督导塑造工具”（supervision shaping tool）。大家说他们觉得这真的很有用。你可以通过节目简介或帖子描述中的链接自行下载。但万一你在收听时手头没有笔，网址是：www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/supervision。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。请务必订阅、点赞、分享、评论，把我们推荐给你的朋友，在你的社交媒体上分享我们。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，我将在周一早上6点的下一期《有志心理学家播客》中再次与大家见面。保重。谢谢。走在通往合格的路上。这里是《有志心理学家播客》，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我叫亚娜（Jana），我是一名见习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。
I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我发现书中所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历真的非常有趣。通往这一职业的路径竟然有这么多，这让我感到非常惊奇，而且成为临床心理学家并没有什么完美的途径，这让我充满信心，意识到我并没有做错，并减轻了我的自我压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始阅读，你就不会把书放下来。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。